بسم الله الرحمن
[موسيقى]
الرحيم اذا هذا الزمن قد و بحسب ماكونل
فيما يتعلق بهجمات الحوثيين التي الاختراق
وارد لاسباب تقنيه تتعلق بمنظومه الرادار
الخاصه بهذه السفينه قد تكون اخطاء بشريه
انا اقول ان الخطا بشري اكثر منه التقني
في البريطانيه للملاحه عن اندلاع حارق على
متن سفينه تجاريه اذا نحن امام حادثه
جديده من جراء اقتراب احد
القوارب باتجاه هذه السفينه وهم مجموعه من
المسلحين وتبادلوا الاطلاق اطلاق النار
معهم بعد استهداف سفينه النفط البريطانيه
لندن تطلب المساعده العاجله ليستهدف ابو
اليمن بعدها مدمره امريكيه وتعلن الولايات
المتحده فرض عقوبات جديده على حكومه صنعاء
اول رد عبري على جنوب افريقيا بعد قرار
المحكمه الدوليه فيما واشنطن تطالب بسحب
الدعوه والاتحاد الاوروبي يؤيد الجنائيه
الدوليه والجزائر تتخذ خطوه متقدمه في
مجلس الامن الدولي لتاييد المحكمه دوله
جديده تقدم طلبا للعدل الدولي للمشاركه في
مقاضاه تلبيب الصين تستجيب لامريكا وتضغط
على ايران لتامين البحر الاحمر واوكرانيا
تدخل نظاما دفاعيا جديدا لصد طائرات موسكو
المسيره وروسيا تزود جيشها في اوكرانيا ب
3500 مسيره ومئات الطائرات المقاتله مع
اكثر من 7000 وحده من
الاسلحه من ساحه البحر الى قاعه
المحكمه اصابات مباشره في خليج عدن كما هي
في البحر الاحمر للجيش اليمني وبعد ان كان
الناطق الرسمي العسكري لحكومه صنعاء يحيى
سريه قد قال ان بلاده نفذت عمليه استهدفت
ناقله النفط البريطانيه مارلين لواندا في
خاليج عدن مؤكدا ان الاصابه كانت مباشره
وادت الى احتراق سفينه النفط هناك قالت
هيئه بحريه بريطانيه ان السفينه المستهدفه
جنوب الشرقي عدن طلبت للمساعده والسلطه
تستجيب ولنتصور
[موسيقى]
وكانت وكاله امبري ويوكي ام تي او
التابعتين للبحريه البريطانيه افدت بان
صارخين انفجر في المياه قباله السواحل
الجنوبيه لليمن على بعد نحو ميل بحري من
ناقله نفط كانت ترفع علم بانما مشيرين الى
عدم وقوع اي اضرار في الناقله من جانبها
قالت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه سند كوم
ان ابو اليمن اطلق صاروخا بالستيا مضادا
للسفن في اتجاه المدمره الامريكيه يو اس
اس كارني في خليج عدن وهنا نتصفح المصدر
افادت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه بان
الحوثيين اطلقوا صاروخا بالسيا مضادا
للسفن في مناطق سيطرتهم باليمن باتجاه
المدمره الامريكيه المدمر الامريكيه كارني
وبعد مناشده امريكيه للصين ذكرت وكاله
رويترز نقلا عن مصادر ايرانيه مطلعه ان
بيكين طلبت من ايران المساعده في وقف
الهجمات التي يشنها اليمنيون في البحر
الاحمر وطالبت الصين الجانب الايراني
بالتاثير على صنعاء لوقف هجماتها في البحر
الاحمر مشيره الى ان علاقاتها التجاريه مع
طهران ستتاح في حال تضررت مصالح بيكين
التجاريه باي شكل من الاشكال ليرد وزير
الخارجيه يراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان بان
الامن سيعود الى البحر الاحمر اذا توقفت
الحرب في القطاع لتتجه الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا لفرض عقوبات مشتركه على اربعه
من كبار قاده صنعاء العسكريين ردا على
الهجمات التي استهدفت سفنا في البحر
الاحمر لننتقل الى محكمه العدل الجنائيه
الدوليه وبعد ان قبلت المحكمه دعوه جنوب
افريقيا بخصوص انتهاكات الكيان الانسانيه
في القطاع حيث اقرت المحكمه فرض تدابير
مؤقته على تلبي في هذه القضيه لياتي اول
رد عبري على جنوب افريقيا حين افادت
القناه الثان العبريه بان شركه الطيران
العال العبريه ستلغي مسار رحلاتها الى
جوهانسبرغ اكبر مدن جنوب افريقيا في الاول
من ابريل المقبل وقالت القناه انه في ظل
الحرب والدعوه في لهاي فان شركه العال
الغت خط الطيران المباشر الى جنوب افريقيا
وقبل ذلك اعلنت نيكارغوا انها تقدمت بطلب
الى محكمه العدل الدوليه للمشاركه في
القضيه التي رفعت جنوب افريقيا ضد تلبيب
امام المحكمه فيما وصف رئيس الوزراء العبر
نتنياهو الادعاء بانه مشين مؤكدا بان تل
ابيب ستواصل حربها ضد الفصائل حتى تحقق
النصر الكامل ووصف نتنياهو على منصه اكس
قرار المحكمه ضد بلاده بانه محاوله دنيئه
لحرمان تلبيب من حق الدفاع عن نفسها كما
انه تمييز صارخ ضد الدوله العبريه مؤكدا
رفضه لتلك المحاوله من جهته اكد الاتحاد
الاوروبي على لسان مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيب بورال انه
يتوقع تنفيذا كاملا وفوريا لقرار محكمه
العدل الدولي الذي طلبت فيه من تل ابيب ان
تبذل كل ما في وسعها لمنع وقوع اي
انتهاكات في القطاع وقال بوريل ان قرارات
محكمه العدل الدوليه ملزمه للاطراف وعليها
الالتزام بها ويتوقع الاتحاد الاوروبي
تنفيذها الكامله والفوريه والفعال
بالمقابل دع رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
بمجلس النواب الامريكي الجنوب ا افريقيا
الى سحب قضيتها ضد تلبيب من محكمه العدل
وهنا نتصفح
[موسيقى]
المصدر لتعلن وزاره الخارجيه الجزائريه ان
الجزائر تعتزم الدعوه الى انعقاد جلسه
لمجلس الامن الدولي في اقرب وقت ممكن من
اجل تفعيل حكم محكمه العدل الدوليه بشان
تل ابيب وبين هذا وذاك فاد موقع والله
العبري بان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ابلغ
النتنياهو خلال محادثه هاتفيه الاسبوع
الماضي بانه لن يدعم حربا مستمره لمده عام
في
القطاع حرب المسيرات
سلاح المسيرات ارهق اوكرانيا والدعم
الغربي لم يعد يكفي لتدخل كياف نظاما
دفاعيا جديدا للتشويش على الطائرات
المسيره الروسيه في حين تمكن الجيش الروسي
من الدخول لاول مره الى ايف دي افكا
الاوكرانيه احدى نقاط المعارك في شرق لكن
تم صده وفق ما اعلن رئيس بلديه المدينه
فيتالي بباغ لوكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه افادت بان
القوات الروسيه حررت بلده فيسي ووي شمالي
مقاطعه دونيتسك واقتربت اكثر من مدينه
سيفرس الواقعه في المثلث الحدودي بين
لوغانسك ودونيتسك وخاركوف ولنضع المصدر
امامكم لتعزيز دفاعاتها في حربها المستمره
مع روسيا ادخلت اوكرانيا نظاما دفا عيا
جديدا وهو عباره عن اداه للتشويش على
الطائرات المسيره الروسيه لاستخدامه سلاحا
في الحرب مع روسيا وفق ما نقلت مجله
نيوزويك على الطرف المقابل صرح الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خلال لقاء مع
الطلاب المشاركين في العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه بوجود اكثر من 600 الف عسكري روسي
في منطقه العمليه على مساحه تقدر بنحو 2
كيلومتر من جهته افاد المدير العام واحد
مصممي شركه بناء الالات الموحده التابعه
لشركه الاسلحه الصاروخيه التكتيكيه
الروسيه الكساندر ليونوف بان الشركه تعمل
بنشاط وعلى قدم وساق لزياده مدى تحليق
صواريخ اوناكس المجنحه الفرط صوتيه بينما
صرح نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي اليكسي كروفي
روكو بان البحريه الروسيه تلقت في عام
2023 اكثر من 7.7 الف وحده من الاسلحه بما
في ذلك صواريخ كروز بعيده المدى زيركون
وكالب و
واضاف كريف روشك ان شركات صناعه الدفاع
زودت القوات المسلحه الروسيه خلال العام
الماضي باكثر من 100 طائره مقاتله بين
جديده وتم تجديدها و150 طائره هيليكوبتر
و3500 طائره دون تيار اما ميدانيا وفي
تقريرها اليومي اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه سيطره قواتها المسلحه على مواقع
جديده في مختلف محاور القتال وتحييد 740
عسكريا عند محور بانسك في مقاطعه خاركوف
[موسيقى]